a year after the emergency Zach was
brought in the commissioner tasked with
finding out whether or not it was
appropriate to be invoked came back and
said that it was
in a report spanning thousands of pages
in five volumes just as Paul roullo
found cabinet had credible and
compelling information that there was a
threat to the security of Canada just
one of multiple legal grounds roulette
found the federal government was
justified in using the emergencies act
the indication the emergencies Act is a
drastic move roulo said but it is not a
dictorial one the Convoy protested
started in Ottawa in late January 2022
which were low beliefs started off as
lawful but he States lawful protests had
descended into lawlessness culminating
in a National Emergency after careful
reflection
I have concluded that the very high
threshold required for the invocation of
the ACT
was met
during testimony the public order
emergency commission Convoy organizers
routinely stated the hot tubs and bouncy
castles that were symbols of the protest
showed was a peaceful and non-violent
one the judge did not accept this
assertion saying violence and harassment
from protesters seriously impacted the
people of Ottawa dysfunction within the
Ottawa Police and municipal government
and a lack of help from the Ontario
provincial government exacerbated the
problems with Rulo saying the provinces
did not have the capability to handle
the emergency if there was better
preparation in anticipation for the
magnitude of the protests from lower
levels of government we low believed the
emergencies act would not have needed to
be used the emergency that Canada
ultimately faced could likely have been
avoided unfortunately it was not the
majority of the measures the federal
government brought in within the powers
from the ACT were found to be reasonable
by real life the most controversial the
freezing of bank accounts which were low
deemed Justified however he found
freezing the insurance of truckers Park
in Ottawa to be ineffective and
problematic reload provided 56
recommendations as a part of his report
the biggest focusing on how police can
better handle gather information and
deal with major events in the future he
also says all levels of government
should study the impact of social media
including misinformation and
disinformation he added an additional 21
recommendations on how to fine-tune the
emergency act legislation for any
potential future use
Justice Rule's report provides a big
political win for Justin Trudeau who had
maintained in the years since the
emergency Zac was brought in that it was
the appropriate thing to do we'll hear
from the Prime Minister later this
afternoon when he will respond to the
report McKenzie gray Global News
Ottawa